Let's just say if you, you, if you were to
go out there and read every single business
book in the world, every business book in
the world, every biography about a billionaire,
how Rockefeller became a billionaire, how
Carnegie, if you were to study every one of
these guys, there's still eight skills you
couldn't learn from just reading these books.
Eight skills you're not going to learn just
from reading these books.
Many times you guys will ask me questions
on Snapchat or Facebook or Twitter and you'll
say, "Pat, here's my predicament.
Here's the situation I'm in.
What do you think I should do?"
And my ending message to you is the following.
John, I don't have access to all the information.
And I will not get access to all the information
that you have today.
This decision you make is the reason why you
will be judged, whether you'll be successful
or not, so I don't know what you're going
to do.
But good luck to you.
Hopefully you'll make the right decision.
And people say, "I need your help with this."
That's not how it works.
You need to make that decision.
So let's get right into these eight skill
sets.
#1: Heart, can't be taught.
#2: Having a vision cannot be taught.
#3: Reading people can't be taught.
#4: Handling pressure on how you handle pressure,
it can't be taught.
#5: Judging people cannot be taught.
#6: Intuition cannot be taught.
#7: Instincts can't be taught.
#8: Common sense cannot be taught.
So you're watching this and saying, "But Pat,
I've read books how to read people, Man.
I've read lots of good books on reading people."
It can't be taught.
You can learn the seven fundamentals of reading
people.
That's great.
I've read books on how to judge people.
It can't be taught.
These eight things can only be practiced and
caught.
But they cannot be taught.
There are a lot of people, like you know this
whole education with the school thing, right?
And my opinion, when I wrote the book, Drop
Out and Get Schooled, there's a lot of people
that think if I just go to school, I'm going
to be able to go and become successful.
So why is it that there's still such a few
percentage of people that after coming out
of college making six figures.
Why is that?
If our educational system works, why is it
that happens?
Because there are eight things that you cannot
teach!
It can only be caught.
So how can it be caught?
Let's talk about it, because that's probably
the question you're asking.
Let's start off with the first one, crisis.
Crisis forces you and I to learn some of these
skills.
I didn't choose to be in a war and be bombed
167 times in a day by Iraq when I was living
in Tehran, Iran.
I didn't choose that life.
That's crisis.
A person didn't choose to live in a family
where we have a kid that I'm following, I
want to adopt this kid because it really hurts
me when I hear the stories this person's going
through.
That kid cannot sit there and do anything
about the fact that her family's in prison,
drug overdose, this person has to constantly
see.
That kid is in crisis mode.
You see, she can't ever teach you what she's
going through.
It can only be caught.
This is crisis.
Right?
Another one, danger zone, death ground.
What is death ground?
Most people will never experience death ground.
Death ground is when you go to war, you see
so many of these war movies, right?
And you know that one scene where they find
out about this one soldier, where everybody,
this most recent movie that came out, where
a guy said, I'm not going to kill anybody.
He said, I'm not going to kill anybody.
What's the movie called?
Hacksaw Ridge, where this kid says, Listen,
since everybody's killing each other, I think
the least I can do is just save lives.
And they found that this guy was the bravest
out of all the other guys.
He didn't want to kill anybody.
But he was the bravest.
Oh my God, he gained everybody's respect.
And he didn't kill anybody.
That's fire right there.
But you have to put him in crisis, death ground
to figure that part out.
The other story about fury.
Remember the movie, Fury, with Brad Pitt?
He tells the kid, he says, c'mon, pull the
trigger.
No, I can't do it.
he starts crying. he starts peeing.
That's death ground.
That's crisis.
That's pressure.
That type of stuff that you will never find
out about who you are until you're in a position
like that.
You just will not.
Another one is life-changing events.
What's life-changing events?
A loss of a loved one, a bankruptcy, an absolute
challenging thing that happens in your family
life, in your personal life.
A certain recovery you make from health, hospitalization
that almost cost you everything.
You know, a conference you go to that completely
changes your view about life.
And you sit down and you have a conversation
with one human being that completely shifts
the way you look at life.
And there's a major paradigm shift.
No one can teach that to you.
That can only be experienced.
You can only sit there.
I know a lot of people say, "Well, you know,
movies, when you watch American Gangster with
what's the guy's name?
Frank Lucas.
Frank Lucas is around the other guy, he had
to shadow this guy to see exactly all this
stuff because that stuff cannot be taught.
It has to be caught.
It's got to be caught.
So what am I telling you here right now?
Look, unless if you put yourself in positions
where your back is against the wall, I just
have to tell you, not a lot is going to happen
where you're going to find out these skills.
It's just not a lot's going to happen.
You talk to any major poker player that's
a champion now, they're going to tell you
at one point they faced somebody that crushed
them, that they didn't know how to handle.
They had to put themselves in death ground
type of situations.
You talk to any athlete, when Michael Jordan,
people started saying, "Who's the great one?"
that shot was shot in North Carolina.
They found out this kid's got heart.
They found out that he can handle pressure.
Man, that's MJ.
This dude is not afraid of pressure.
This guy can handle it.
When your team is down one point, and there's
one second left on the shot clock, you're
shooting two free throws, they're going to
find out if you're cold as ice.
That's pressure.
That is pressure.
When you've got to go close this sale, or
else you're going to be out of business, and
you go in there not knowing how to handle
pressure, you panic because all you're thinking
about is your bills, bills, bills, bills,
bills, and you don't know how to handle that
sale, and you lose it because the client can
tell the fear on your eyes, that's handling
pressure.
See, we don't know everything about you.
This whole thing about life, we put so much
stuff about motivation, positive thinking,
you can go get it!
There is a chance, maybe you really don't
want to go out there and do it because the
last point I'm going to make in this video
is a very simple point.
And here's what the point is.
Listen up, very closely.
Seven billion people are living in the world.
We can measure this [heart], we can't measure
your judgment.
We can't measure your pressure - we can't
measure any of that stuff.
But there's one thing that only you can answer.
And let me tell you what it is.
If it's important to you, if it's important
to you, I guarantee you you'll figure it out.
If it's not important to you, I guarantee
you you'll figure it out.
But that's the part no one can do anything
about.
Not me, not the greatest philosophers of all
time, not the greatest minds of all time.
We put them all in a room together and we
said, "Let's move you."
We can't do it.
Because we don't know what's here [inside],
man.
We don't know what you got.
We don't.
That's the part when I message back and I
say, prove it!
Show the world!
What are you all about?
You!
Learn these eight things by putting yourself
in crisis situations, death ground, back is
against the wall, you have to figure out a
way to fight like hell to get out of it.
Then when you're in that moment and you say,
"un uh, I give up."
Yep!
We just found out what you're all about.
And you just found out what you're all about.
It's no one's responsibility.
But you just figured out a lot about yourself
because I guarantee you if it's important
to you, you'll figure it out.
This is why the same family has four kids,
and one becomes a rock star, the other two,
they all handle the exact same problem.
What happened?
Because to somebody it was very important.
Because to you it was very important.
Because to the other person it was very important.
Only you can answer that.
Only you can.
So, yes, in a way, these eight can be taught,
but it can only be taught if you have the
desire to catch these eight skills.
If you have no willingness and the desire
to want to catch these eight skills, you're
never going to have them at the highest level.
Everybody already has a little bit of it,
but not at the highest level we can monetize
it at high levels and really make an impact
on other people's lives.
So I hope today's message kind of gives you
different perspectives.
There's a lot of how-tos on Valuetainment,
but today's message is just kind of tugging
at your heart a little bit.
Speaking to you a little bit.
Like what are you really made up of?
Go show the world what you're really made
up of.
We all want to find out what you, I'm talking
to you.
What are you made up of?
We want to find out.
Everyone wants to find out.
Your family wants to find out.
Your peers want to find out.
More importantly, your spirit wants to find
out what you've got to show to the world.
Paul, let's get that pillow here.
This is an exciting episode.
I hope the right message was given to you
where it's stirring your soul, and maybe listen
to it one more time and maybe share this with
your team and take notes on this and start
really pause after you're done watching it
and ask some real questions of yourself.
Truly.
How do you handle pressure?
Ask these questions of yourself.
Who are you?
How do you handle these things?
Hey, if you haven't subscribed after a video
like this, maybe I even understand because,
you say, Pat, this is too much pressure.
But if you haven't subbed and you want more
videos like this, click sub here, and if you
haven't joined the notification squad, click
on that as well because you'll be one of the
first to get the videos and if you got any
questions, comments, thoughts about this video,
post your comments on the bottom.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.